[Music]
so this thing that happened it's already
finished they caught the dude it's all
done
uh
but there are some details that are kind
of new that are coming out but also more
importantly we got christian here today
so we can hear from him
the brooklyn subway shooting yeah
we didn't get to cover that because uh
that happened a couple of weeks ago and
we weren't together but just a summary
for those who don't know yeah you got to
fill me in i don't know what happened so
oh you know what why don't you talk
about the brooklyn shooting from your
perspective yeah well uh on like what
day was it was it thursday at eight
o'clock in the morning
like there was a
there was a guy that went to the subway
that planted smoke bombs everywhere and
shot like 13 people oh my gosh and the
only reason he didn't keep going because
he's gun jammed
but he like shot and injured like 13
people in the subway while the subway
was moving whoa when they got to the
stop everyone like ran out there was
like smoke everywhere oh my god and the
[ __ ] up thing is the guy got away
like he just walked out he just got out
like yeah he escaped like he fled the
scene holy [ __ ] and the problem right
now in new york is like uh the new mayor
just put eric adams just put a bunch of
cops in the subway there's like more
cops than ever in the subway and this
like still happened
so everyone's fine so the cops there's
more cops than ever and this still
happens yeah yeah [ __ ] that's crazy
where were the cops at if there were
more cops are they our flappy birds are
they in the are they are laughing birds
are good are they part of the like
they're in the subway as it's going or
they're oh no no there's no cops in the
cars though oh so they don't look like
regular people and they're trying to act
like civilians no no see like an air
marshal they should have a train marshal
that's what we need another day in the
rat race am i right
suitcases
[Laughter]
they're like you're an undercover kind
of relate to people
go to work
the subway
i got my sabaro with me all ready for
the day
like just are you a cop because i'm from
new york what no imagine overselling
being a civilian
how do you oversell that man i sure
missed those two towers
this is your this is the character
you've always
been made to play with a new york accent
never forget
don't you just
what do you think about first responders
personally not so bad
i think they get a bad rap they're
trying to like repair their rep while
playing that civilian character
anyways i'm just a normal
[Laughter]
there's a briefcase full of work
of
work the cops are [ __ ] up they could
have been doing that the whole time
god walking around like real cops
in the subway is a funny phrase dude i
love i love a fake cop bro
i love an overselling fake i love it
undercover cop so [ __ ] i was trying to
find him in coachella i was trying to
look because there's something
everywhere you guys selling e you guys
selling e
hey
is that his actual gun yeah yeah yeah
yeah hey what could i get her extra
seats
you guys got molly anyway i got some
money there was this one picture of uh i
think it was like maybe a few years ago
but it was at a festival and there was
like these three or four dudes with like
cargo shorts and polo these on and a
g-shock
and
[Laughter]
short haircut with like like oakley
and a cell phone holder yeah i wonder
who they are
sperry's on
that's [ __ ] funny did you see anybody
that you were like doesn't i couldn't
find any damn they're going to be
they were told to dress casually and
blended they're getting better man
they're just blending in yeah they just
look like frat bros now yeah you know so
what what was the brooklyn community's
like thoughts and feelings about that
little [ __ ] dude like no one caught the
subway the next day first
or like like my friend that catches the
subway to work was like he was like oh
dude it was there were like two people
in this car and everyone's like on edge
like tripping yeah because like by the
the next day they didn't catch the guy
yet they caught the guy like two days
ago two days later yeah so they thought
they were going to hit again yeah cause
like he wasn't done so everyone walked
to work because there were bombs that
were planted like unexploded bombs
how many did they end up fighting a lot
because he left green gas too i mean i
saw like a video as like green gas yeah
there were smoke bombs there were smoke
bombs because people were coughing and
[ __ ] he dropped his credit card yeah on
the scene and they were able to find
that he rented a u-haul that's how they
got it how did he drop his credit card
no this guy honestly i was thinking like
bro
you kind of suck yeah for real he got it
he couldn't get his gun jam he didn't
know how to unclog it what was he doing
like searching for his [ __ ] money
while he was like in the middle of it
all his credit card dropped out like
that's such a weird thing you probably
have all those wallets that you gotta
spin around because of the rubber band
or he's just one of those guys that just
puts all these cards in his pocket oh i
do that he loves
yeah you matches
put just put i know i've seen like even
out of restaurants and stuff people just
have cards and money and they're
in their pockets that's why they need
ridge wallet yeah
thank you ridge
he just throws it in his pocket and they
found a bunch of other [ __ ] in that
u-haul didn't they they were yeah
there's a bunch of weird this guy like i
honestly didn't look up after the fact
like but like during um
a lot of my friends that just started
like that work at offices like they just
started like going back to the office so
after that it's funny because the office
is like you know what you guys don't
need to come in it's actually not that
bad right now so
people right now are like not digging
the subway because you know wow it's
weird so they're still traumatized from
what happened oh yeah oh i bet you are
guns legal or
no new york has pretty strict gun laws
gee i don't know when it's so illegal i
don't know how this guy got a hand he
bought it at an ohio pawn shop
yeah the gun that he used they traced it
back and then that's where he got it are
bombs illegal
now that they're smoked it's okay
in the subway
to a certain radius yeah
did you hear about it while it was
happening yeah i heard like i woke up to
it whoa oh my god yeah i woke up to like
text from my girlfriend like oh my god
there was a bombing at the station and i
was saying this like
she catches the subway that same line to
work oh my god
she works in manhattan and she lives in
brooklyn yeah but like we kind of like
live together now and i live like up
like from
i live closer to work from that stop
but if she like was staying at home and
caught the um the train to work she
would have been at that station at that
time whoa
that's [ __ ] damn that's so crazy what
did she do sleep in that day so she was
like no no she just ubered to work yeah
just felt like ubering that day yeah
just randomly mm-hmm well yeah she's
just been ubering lately but yeah i
would too yeah because it's like you
know it's also just faster yeah yeah
but yeah if she had caught the train it
would have been at that stop which is
like [ __ ] weird to think about did
you see the stuff where he was yelling
like slurs and [ __ ] yeah he looked up
his old content oh dude i watch his
content on youtube he's like a black
nationalist like he hates like he's like
totally radical like on youtube so he's
like a skinhead but a black version but
he also says [ __ ] about black people too
so it kind of threw everybody off a
little bit they were like wait what
but yeah he does hate on a lot of other
races he's just like a like a radical
hate person did he have a manifesto not
really but he did um basically turn
himself in he he called the tip line and
tipped out himself why that's how they
caught him people are because he
couldn't go anywhere they just had a car
on the floor they basically shrunk his
world to like a dot because they were
like everyone [ __ ] knows what you
look like and where like they were just
looking for him so hardcore that he just
called in he was like hey i heard you're
looking for me i'm gonna be at this i'll
be at this mcdonald's or whatever like
come get me
yeah also apparently it's like dude the
city's gonna use everyone's complaining
that the city's gonna use this as a ploy
to put even more cops in the
so they're going to leverage that yeah
is that a bad thing do they get in the
way
well the thing is like the cops don't
really stop anything
bad like this like they should have
stopped this but they didn't but then
the things that they're catching people
for like people jump in the terms turn
styles like who cares about that yeah i
see so people get mad that the cops are
like making unnecessary arrests for
people that are already less fortunate
like if you're jumping up coming tsa
yeah like if you're jumping a one dollar
25 turn style you probably need it you
know you probably can't afford it yeah
like they're they're they're really hard
on the harmless crimes but the violent
crimes nothing's happening yeah like
people are still getting pushed into the
yeah into the tray yeah but i see a new
video every week yeah like the cops
aren't able to stop that because it's
like kind of hard how they man i want
them to stop all the [ __ ] asian hate
[ __ ] that's been going on in new york
like the [ __ ] are they doing yeah what
about that guy that was [ __ ] in that
bucket remember that video that was
hilarious
who's stopping that guy bro he's been
getting one arrest there has been a lot
of like asian like hate crime happening
a lot did you see that one video i don't
know if it's like set up or not but it
was these two dudes that look like
they're gonna get down and they're
[ __ ] yelling at each other like this
i was gonna [ __ ] go down it looks
like it's about to fight and you see
these two like asian ladies oh [ __ ] so
they they walk away but then they start
[ __ ] battling each other and then
they once they started battling each
other this actual homeless man with no
shirt came out came came from the other
car into that car and then the other two
days were like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i think they were trying to set
something up but that that uninvited
homeless man freaked everyone out
that's what you get playing stupid
[ __ ] jokes that's what you get dude
oh yeah so this is
so this is the new so once they caught
the guy and everything now there's this
new thing going around which is really
being debunked hardcore but people think
it's a false flag
everyone doesn't trust nothing no more
dude because because conveniently none
of the cameras worked that day yeah no
that was weird yeah
yeah what do you think about that i
don't know like why the [ __ ] does that
always happen yeah
i'm starting to think we don't even have
cameras honestly
i bet a lot of places just have cameras
that don't even work yeah i think that's
i think that's what it is it's just like
most uh old surveillance systems that
are not working
haven't been working it's just really
shitty maintenance yeah yeah and it's
like last on the list because nobody
wants to pay the ring membership a month
i was gonna say like when like i mean
that's right adt is pretty expensive was
that like 36th street like when was the
last time anyone needed a camera for
that station you know what i mean and
that station's been around for years
so it's like they're probably like
they'll start recording now yeah so two
days before so there's not a fat dude
that's like with a pathologist
sitting here with a [ __ ] big and he's
eating a donut and he's watching
watching american gladiators or another
[Laughter]
nah man that's what they said is two
days before the attack they reported a
fiber optic cable connection failure on
the camera so none of them
came out
yeah what was the deep why did they
debunk that is because um
there is footage from other cameras just
not the ones right there like all the
ones that are immediately right where it
happened they weren't working but uh
they still got camera footage of it they
got
like civilian camera footage though yeah
there was a viral video of like when the
train got there and all the smoke came
out a bunch of people running out yeah
that's what i saw yeah
i saw the one in the car where
they were shooting sounds and then there
was a guy that was trying to get him
from one door to the other and people
were just like yeah i'm running out of
time yeah so they they pretty much
proved that it wasn't a a stage camera
thing by showing how badly their
maintenance normally is because they
said in 2018
223 cameras in 10 stations
31 percent of them never got the
maintenance done yeah i was gonna say
wow it's just broken all yeah it's just
like shitty maintenance i know someone
that works at target and she was telling
me that like half their cameras at
target don't even work yeah that makes
sense dude the only place where the
cameras work are [ __ ] right above the
pit boss in vegas
[Laughter]
it is crazy though how like when the big
events like that will like stop
something because uh in arizona they had
the the freeway shooter do you guys
remember oh yeah yeah yeah
and i had moved already at that time but
my dad was there and so you're not a
suspect we were saying no i wasn't a
suspect
but my dad and my brother both were
taking videos the next couple days on
the freeway not a like not a single car
like on the freeways because everybody
was scared because then there was a
bunch of copycats people shooting people
with bb guns on all exits of the
freeways and stuff because i always
think like right after a tragedy it's
like the best time because no one's
there and that's good the least likely
to hit twice just probability like vegas
no dude i forget what it was there's a
guy that's like known
like i forget where i watched the video
but there's this guy that like books
travel to the place whenever there's a
tragedy because it's like because it's
so dirt cheap yeah and there's no one in
the way
he must be in ukraine right now
he's probably been there for a minute he
was like he was on a plane ukraine or
shanghai
delisha he's a guy that's buying all the
murder houses and like [ __ ] haunted
places and [ __ ]
loki i went to hawaii during the
pandemic
it was the best time of my
life i had waikiki all to myself you are
problematic
you